– Hat’s geschmeckt?
– Sehr gut, vielen Dank!
– Passt schon, geht aufs Haus.
– Aber ich bin der böse Bruder.
Schon vergessen?
– Aber nicht mein böser Bruder.
– Danke.
– Konntest du denn mit Nico reden?
– Mehr oder weniger. Wir haben ja seit
Jahren kaum Kontakt.
– Wieso eigentlich nicht?
– Das ist ’ne lange Geschichte.
– Hm.
Ich hab Zeit.
– Ich bin der Älteste und war irgendwie
schon immer der Lieblingssohn meiner Eltern.
Nach der Schule hab ich
im Gegensatz zu Nico studiert
und das Studium dann mit ’ner sehr
guten Note abgeschlossen.
Dann bin ich nach Deutschland gegangen,
um hier eine Firma zu gründen.
– Wow.
– Unsere Eltern waren sehr stolz,
denn sie wollten einen Arzt, Anwalt oder
Geschäftsführer in der Familie haben.
Mein Vater hat immer gesagt:
„Ihr müsst Medizin, Maschinenbau oder
Jura studieren. Das hat Zukunft.“
– Und Nico wollte das nicht.
– Nico ist kein Akademiker.
Nico will anpacken
– beruflich und privat.
Er wollte immer ’n Handwerk lernen.
– Ich verstehe. Aber das ist doch nicht der
Grund, weshalb er nicht mit dir redet.
– Nein. Der Grund ist,
dass ich ihn nie unterstützt hab.
– Und jetzt willst du es wiedergutmachen?
– Keine Ahnung …
– Vertrauen entsteht nicht von heute
auf morgen.
– Ich weiß. Ich kann warten.
– Deine Firma, was macht die denn so?
– Wir entwickeln Apps und im Prinzip
alles, was digital ist.
– Echt?
– Ja. Wieso?
– Ich hab da schon lange eine Idee …